I'm John Strowmire and I'm a troop order of the Arrow Representative Advisor with
Troop 55 in Houston, Texas. This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is
sponsored by backers like me. God thanks so much for all you do
with the podcast And now for you, Scoutmaster.
So there are three things that make for good Scoutmasters: men at a good
beginning, a good ending, and the third thing is that there's not much else
in between.
Hey, this is podcast number 251..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag. Thomas Keppley got in touch. He said: I found
your new book so far, so good and became a backer to get an autographed copy.
I'm officially taking over the reins as Scoutmaster for our troop,
Troop 37 in Indian Waters Council at our Court of Honor next week. Wish me
good luck, And I do Thomas good luck, good fortune,
bon voyage
and all that kind of great stuff. I'm sure you're going to love the job.
And thanks for becoming a backer, and we'll talk a little bit more about that
in a moment. I had a couple of people write in
about podcast 250.. One asked to remain anonymous
but he said: wow, that was a great podcast Seriously. I've been tuned in for
about a year and that might be the best episode I've
heard yet. It really resonated with me. As my son came into Scouts, I had
expectations about how Scouts would fulfill requirements like you
explained, But I have, in part because of your
podcast, shifted my thinking. I love the message that all of us-
Scouts and Scouters, Eagle Scouts, everyone-
were always on the Eagle path, looking to live by the tenets
of the Scout Oath and Law. Also heard from Peter
Balje or Baljet about podcast 250..
Just a short note to say congratulations on episode 250.
It's a great achievement. Each podcast is full of great advice
and that is not an easy accomplishment. I'm a new assistant scoutmaster
at Troop 21 in Atlanta, Georgia, and your podcast has been my most valuable
training tool. Well, Peter, I'm always happy to hear that people are
getting something out of the podcast. I really appreciate you getting in touch.
Let's see, this past week had a lot of folks check in on the chat.
Wow, that's a long list of names. Let's run down.
Scoutmaster Stoltz is in Troy, Ohio, with Troop 365..
Simon's from Texas. Dennis Unger, one of our frequent fliers in Troop 13
in Watumka, Alabama. Bill McFarland in Pittsfield, Massachusetts.
James is the Scoutmaster Troop 104 in Gulf Breeze, Florida.
Danny Van Pelt in Mississippi checked in. Steve Cottrell
and Dave Smiley have become kind of frequent fliers too.
Bradley White-Fendison, 29 Palms, California, who's a scoutmaster and
roundtable commissioner. Tim Z checked in, As did John Nelson,
another frequent flier. Dale Austin is an assistant scoutmaster in
Tallahassee, Florida. Rhonda Ruff-Wyman has been on the
chat a few times before too, and she's a scoutmaster in rural Missouri.
And finally Todd Lund, who's a scoutmaster in Little Egg Harbor, New Jersey.
The live chat feature will go live. most of the time It's on a weekday morning,
And if you keep up with the Facebook feed or the Twitter feed,
you'll get announcements. When we're having a live chat you can check in and say
hello. I had this email and this is an important one.
Not that they're all important, but this one is especially
important, at least to me personally. It's from Tom Gillard in
Tallahoma, Tennessee, who wrote in to say I am technically
retired as a scoutmaster now. Officially it's really not supposed
to happen until the end of March, when the charter is renewed,
but I'm pretty much retired now. In the past 21 years, 50 of my 187 boys
made eagle and they had a retirement ceremony for me,
and 30 of those 50 showed up and it was pretty touching.
Wow, that's really something, Tom. Scouts stood up and told stories about
their lives in the troops, some having to do with some of my strange ways.
My two sons gave their perspective and then my daughter lost it up and told
about her perspective of being married to an eagle scout.
I will remain on the district committees and I will do some things with our
council. I started hiking with a group. I got an
email from the president of our local natural area asking if I'd consider
being on the board of directors. You don't know how much your advice is
meant to me as a scoutmaster Kept me somewhat sane-
somewhat being the effective term there, right, Tom?
Thank you for all of your support over the years.
I crawled out of the volcano and survived and, Clark, you know the feeling
and I do. I'm a recently retired scoutmaster
and Tom has been a friend and a participant in these podcasts
in our Scoutmasters panel. Godspeed, Tom, and our best wishes to you,
and we'll continue to correspond and you continue to
all of that good energy and wisdom that you've accumulated over 21 years as a
scoutmaster. Congratulations, my friend, If you regularly
read the Scoutmaster blog and you're a listener to the Scoutmaster podcast
and if those resources have helped you, you can return the favor
by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
Now, the funds we get from backers go towards the expenses of producing and
publishing the blog posts and the podcasts and the videos,
and we want to do our best to keep them freely available so they're accessible
to scouts all over the world. and lots of people check in every single week,
and the only way that this happens is because we have
the support of our backers. Now it's very easy to do:
go to scoutmastercgcom and click the support link you'll find at the top
of the page. You can choose any level of support. Some of them entitle you to
premiums like autograph copies of my books, and within the past week,
here are the folks that did just that, who went to scoutmastercgcom,
followed the support link and became backers. I want to take a moment to
personally thank Daryl Oakley, Tom Thomas Keppley, Daniel Weeks,
John Murtaugh and somebody who I'll just call George,
who said that I didn't have to mention that they became a backer.
I kind of did. It was a little sneaky of me, George. I hope it doesn't make
you upset, But I want to really thank all of those
folks for their support, Go to scoutmastercgcom and become a
backer this week, and I'll be sure to thank you personally
during our next podcast. In this week's podcast- and scout
master ship in seven minutes or less, we're going to talk about five basic
ways to make the most of your opportunity as a
scouter, and then I've got a couple of email questions to answer. so let's get
started, shall we? Scout master ship in seven minutes
or less?
So you've signed on and you've become a scouter, You've filled out the forms,
you've got your uniform and your necrochiff
and your patch, and what are you going to do to make the most of that
opportunity? Because it's a really precious opportunity,
isn't it? It's, it's wonderful work to be able to do.
So what are the? the basic five things that you need to know?
And here they are, and I think they're all probably equally important.
The first thing I would say that will help you make
the most of your opportunity is to trust the program,
And when I talk about the program, I'm talking about the broad
underlying principles of scouting and the specifics in the way that your
particular scouting organization is directing you to apply
those principles. Scouting has been around since
1907 and in that more than a century.
everything that's going to happen has happened in one way or another.
People have encountered these challenges. they've overcome them
and we share how to make that happen with each other
in ways like the podcast, but there's also training courses. There are
people who will help you locally. trust the program.
There's an over a century of experience involved in it.
Now specific applications of the program are going to change now and again
in your organization and embrace those changes when they are now. Stay
current. Keep up with what's going on. Make sure that you read and understand
what's what's happening in your scouting organization.
Don't, don't take any shortcuts. Do it all the hard way
You know. actually do the program. It's very, very important. And remember
that shortcuts make things easier for adults, but you usually
diminish the experience for scouts. So the first one: trust the program.
The second one is: conduct activities that are age appropriate.
You have to understand how the scouting program
responds to the age group that you're working with. Whether you're working
with cub scouts, scouts, ventures, rovers, whatever you're
working with, you need to focus on age appropriate
activities, Foster a sense of growing personal responsibility and
initiative, no matter what the age of of the scouts that you're working
with. Know how to manage risks and promote safety
in all the activities. That's really, really important
because we want our scouts to have great, adventurous experiences that are
safe too. We can't eliminate risk, but we can
understand those risks and we can manage them
appropriately. So we trust the program and we conduct activities that are age
appropriate. And the third one is be prepared to work with other people,
And that should be fairly self-evident, but a lot of us find this kind of
challenging. I know I do at times. You're going to
work with different family standards and expectations.
The way that you raised your kids is not exactly the right way for
everybody else to raise their children- and you're working with parents
and children and you're going to run into different expectations,
different family standards, and you have to learn to work with those.
With your fellow scoutingers, you want to do your best to avoid
disagreements, Policy disagreements. you can bring those to a
swift resolution with as little disruption as possible
by getting the resources, and we- you know there's a there's a saying abroad in
scouting- run to the resource. So there's lots of
explanatory materials out there offered by your scouting organization.
If you disagree on something with another scouter,
go to the resource and let that define where you're going to be
and resolve any disagreements quickly. Scouters at the top of the organization
chart, like scout masters, like cub masters, like venture crew advisors,
committee chairs- the folks who volunteer for those positions are
usually the kind of personalities that feel very confident in their abilities
to get things done. but all of us need to be able to accept help,
And what I have found personally is that you have to accept help
that doesn't do things exactly the way that you would do them.
You have to be able to work with that. You can't have perfect help all the time.
You can't have people who will do things exactly the way that you want to do them,
but don't complain that you're doing everything if you're not accepting
any help from anybody because you're the only one who can do it correctly.
If you find that advice confusing, you have no idea what I'm talking about.
You probably already accept help, but if that touches a chord, you know exactly what
I'm talking about. right, Accept help. Let people do things their own way.
They may not do them exactly as you would like, but things will get done.
and when you're working with other people, you also need to exercise
professionalism, and you wouldn't think we would talk about
professionalism in the context of volunteerism,
but what I'm saying is that, yes, you're not a paid professional,
but you need to have that sense of being responsible
for what's going on in a professional manner.
We never use the excuse. well, you know, I'm only a volunteer, I only have so much
time I can't really make that happen. No, we work the program-
that was point number one right. Trust the program, follow the program,
conduct age appropriate activities and we need to exercise measure of
professionalism in the way that we do that. So we trust the program,
we conduct age appropriate activities. we were prepared to work with
other adults and other people and we maintain perspective and proportion,
and there's a lot about scouting that comes down to your perspective
and maintaining a sense of proportion about things.
Don't let the perfect be the enemy of the good.
Things will rarely be perfect, especially when you're working with scouts in a
scout troop or a venture crew. they're learning what they're doing.
we entrust them with a lot of leadership responsibility and they are
going to exercise it imperfectly. and don't get distracted by requiring
things to be perfect. Look for initiative, look for action
and build on that and it'll get better as time goes by,
but don't let the perfect be the enemy of the good. Another really important part
of our perspective as scouts is that all of scouting
is an individual standard based on the scouts effort, and that's one of the
things that makes scouting different from just about everything else that our
young people do. We reward initiative and effort on an
individual basis because that builds confidence,
and confidence builds proficiency and competence
in the different skills, whether it's lighting a fire
or leading a patrol. we know that effort is important,
we recognize it, and we recognize it not according to what that guy over
there did, but what one individual scout is
doing. Perspective and proportion are also really important. when it comes to what
you do for scouting. You need to keep the commitments that you make
and not overextend yourself. We talk about this a lot of times about
wearing different hats, and I get emails from folks with
long lists of responsibilities that they've taken on in scouting in the
signature block and I think that's very laudable.
but we're talking about maintaining perspective and proportion.
don't overextend yourself. There are always more
roles in scouting in a district, in a council, even in a unit, than there are
people to take them on, and I think a lot of times that means
people wear a couple of different hats. I'm not going to tell you a number that
you're allowed to wear or anything like that, but you have to keep some
proportion and perspective in the number of responsibilities you take on.
Once again, don't overextend yourself. One of the things that is
certain to happen: if you hang around long enough: you're going to encounter
a problem or a difficulty. that is a new challenge for you,
but it's not a new challenge to scouting. There's a world of good ideas out there
and, as we said before when we're talking about trusting the program,
scouting's been around for more than a century now.
just about every possible permutation of challenge that's come along has
come along. You're going to meet one that you
aren't familiar with. while you can maintain a little
perspective and proportion by understanding, somebody's already been there
and they've already figured a way out and what you need to do is to tap into that
kind of group knowledge, Ask for help, accept some help,
because you're not likely to encounter a new problem or a new difficulty.
We've already been there before in scouting at one time or another.
Now, if you're the parent of a scout and a volunteer at the same time,
you have to exercise a little perspective and proportion with your own
child For an hour a week, right, or whatever amount of time you spend in your
role as a scout, or every week. you're a scout or first and a parent second.
You have more scouts to serve than just your child.
There's a corollary to that. on the opposite side
is not making things more difficult for your child just because they're your
child. So when you're, when you're a scout, or be
a scout, or let your child be a scout. when you're a parent, be a parent,
let your child be your child. How about that? Know the difference between those
two roles and try not to switch back and forth
in them during scouting activities very often.
Sometimes a child needs a parent, sometimes a scout needs a
scouter. You know what I'm talking about: right, Perspective
and proportion. So we're trusting the program, we're conducting age-appropriate
activities, we're prepared to work with other adults,
we're maintaining perspective and proportion. and the fifth and final
thought for today is focusing on the goal, the main aim of scouting,
And the main aim is always the success of your scouts.
Now, if that's reflected in really great metrics that you can post on a wall
somewhere, that's fine. but that's not always going to be the case.
The success of your scouts, like we said before, is
on an individual basis, according to effort, and you have to pay attention to
scouts on an individual basis. If you pay attention to scouts and
heard like a big, giant troop or even in a patrol,
well you may have a successful troop or a successful patrol, but you're going to
have some scouts who aren't all that successful because you're not paying
attention to them. You need to pay attention to scouts
on an individual basis because the aim is the success of that individual
scout. We want to make sure that we're preparing
our scouts for the next step in the program, for the next thing that comes
along. We want to ease the transition points in
scouting between cubs and scouts and scouts and ventures, by
making sure that we understand what comes next.
We want our scouts to experience things rather than think about things or do
things theoretically right. We want them to go camping.
We want them to do stuff. We don't want them sitting somewhere
listening to us talk about doing stuff. We want them to do stuff. so we want to
focus on experiences because in those experiences
we're going to reach our aim, which is positively affecting the
character of young people with the scouting program
right. So focus on making sure they have the opportunity for those
experiences- and everything else will follow in that- And then finally
strive to understand your role and maintain your scouting education.
You'll learn something new just about every time.
Read some of the resources or talk with your fellow scouters.
This is a very rich field. There's a lot to learn, There's a lot to know
And be satisfied with the idea that none of us are ever going to arrive at the
point where we are total master expert scouts.
We're always developing. There's always something new to know And there's
likely going to be some kind of change in an adjustment
And our attitudes are in the way that we do things that are going to
benefit our scouts. So strive to understand your role
and maintain your scouting education. So, once again, these are five
things that help you make the most of your opportunity as a
scouter: Trust the program, Conduct activities that are age-appropriate,
Be ready to work with other people, Maintain perspective and proportion
and focus on the main aim, the goal of scouting.
Now you've got your trucker's hitch
Email- that is, folks- And here's an answer to one of your emails.
I had this email question from Joel Diebel and he said I'm a
scouter of nearly 20 years, mostly in Cubs and Boy Scouts in Idaho.
We just moved to Utah and I was recently asked to be
adventuring Roundtable. Commissioner, I'm new to
venturing. I'm trying to learn as much about it as I can.
I'm trained and I've attended and staffed Wood Badge.
I know and teach the patrol method, But what I'm after are ideas and
resources specific to venturing. Well, Joel, I am a crew advisor
now myself and I've found that there's not a whole lot of
difference between the broad underlying concepts that
motivate our work in Cubs, because I've been a Cub Master before
and in a Scout Troop, because I've been a Scout Master before
and in a Venturing Crew. No matter what the age or program,
everything is built on the same foundational ideas and that's what I
try to stick with Now in venturing. the age, appropriateness of
the activities and the fact that it's a co-ed program add a
couple of challenges in there, but those are reasonably easy to
overcome and to understand if you go to the venturing
resources, especially venturing youth protection guidelines.
But everything else the patrol system is still active in
venturing. It's just got different names, The way that
Scouts develop and the things that they do still active
in venturing. it's got different names. I think if you go ahead
and you study the program in that light, you're going to find
that those similarities will boost your confidence in helping
people understand what venturing is. And I heard back
from Joel after I sent him that email. he said that was the
reassurance I needed. This is a great lesson for me as a
Scouter. No matter how long a person or a Scout is in a
position, some simple reassurance can go a long way.
I'm excited about my new adventure in venturing Now. I had
this email who, and the sender will remain anonymous. I'd be
interested in your thoughts about concerns expressed to me
by a parent about our recent camping trip where
Scouters were camping at some distance away from Scouts.
This is the message I got from the parent. I'm concerned
about hearing that the boys slept in a different camp site
than all the Scout leaders at the last camp out. As a
parent, I'm sure you can understand this concern. My
expectations are that the leaders are always with the
boys and definitely within earshot of them at all
times for their safety. Well, that's a very reasonable
concern. Now parents are going to have those concerns
about supervision in a camping situation. Now we're
talking about Boy Scouts going camping, and I always
recommend that patrols camp in their own camp site, that
they camp a little distance away from other patrols and
from adults, because that's where they can begin to
function as a patrol. Now, if you're, if you've been
listening to the podcast for a while or reading the
blog for a while, this is a subject that often comes
up. So what happens when parents express concerns
about this physical separation when we're doing
what I suggest right? Well, if you think about this
for a moment, Scouts are likely to be some distance
away from Scouts much of the time, no matter what
we're doing. They may be 10 yards away, they may be
5 yards away, they may be 25 yards away or a more
significant distance, but we're always aware of where
they are and we're always aware of what they're up
to, and we're always have the observation goggles
and earpieces in right. Now, if they're out of
sight, they're never out of mind and if they're
out of sight, we know that they're being
supervised by their youth leadership. We've been
working with our youth leadership to the point
where we're competent of their ability to do that.
Now, if a parent will think about it for a moment. in many
day-to-day situations they're going to be farther away
and less cognizant of what their children are doing
than we ever are when we're on a camping trip. and we have to remember too,
camping is a lot different than a visit to a mall,
you know, going to school or many of the other activities that our
children will do every day. They're in a totally different environment,
right, and I think I can safely say that going
camping is statistically safer than driving to the campsite
or being on the bus, going to school or being a passenger in any car.
So we need a little perspective and proportion about the risk involved
with being a bit of a distance away from
scouters during a camping trip. We're in a very different kind of environment.
Now, that being said, that different environment does have its own risks. I
mean, if scouts are using woods tools like pocket knives and saws and
axes and things like that, you know there's a risk involved there
and we're in the outdoors and each one of the environments that we encounter is
going to have its own types of risks. Well, hopefully, what we've done is
prepared the scouts to meet those risks. We've assured ourselves that they
safely know how to use the equipment that they're using,
that they know how to encounter any environmental risks that they may.
they may come on, and if we're not sure about that, well we need to up our
supervision a little bit. So the parent that we're talking
about here said my expectations that the leaders are always with the boys and
definitely with the near shot of them at all times for their safety.
Well, let's talk about specific safety concerns.
So the first one is going to be physical safety. right,
Every injury I can recall needing attention beyond basic first aid
in 30 years of being a scout master happened
within a few feet of where I was standing at, sometimes
right in front of me. If parents are honest with themselves, just about any
time their child was hurt they were probably directly supervising their
child or the child was only a few feet away.
I don't recall many injuries, if any, that happened
without me seeing them happen or having to
only turn around to see what happened. So my proximity to what's going on
does not necessarily mean more safety. So physical safety is one thing.
if they're concerned about issues other than physical safety, like bullying or
any kind of inappropriate activities, parents should be very specific about
those concerns. You know exactly what are they
concerned about and why? Has there been some kind of bullying
that they've heard about them? we need to know: Has their child been
dabbling in things that we should know about?
Have they been smoking or drinking or doing drugs?
We should know about that because if that's a concern to them, if they're
concerned that their child is going to go on a scouting trip,
they're not going to be supervised and they're going to be dabbling in these
things, or they're going to be subject to bullying,
or they may be a bully themselves and the parent is concerned about this because
it's something that they have been dealing with with the child.
We need to know that. so we need to ask them to be very specific about what
those concerns are and address them as they as they arise.
If the parents came home and discovered John had been drinking or
smoking or had been using drugs, or if they've had that happen to them, we need to
know, because then we're going to know what to
supervise and we're going to know what to discuss with our scouts.
I think that once you look at this logically, most parents are going to
understand that their child aren't in danger because they're not
in your direct proximity 100% of the time when you're out on a
camping trip. They're going to understand that we have responsible
youth leadership and we're assured of that responsibility
and we're very observant and sensitive to any kind of risks that our scouts may
encounter when they're in our care. I heard from James Eisenmine
with Troop 104. he said, as a new scout master, swimming in the volcano,
that's a great picture. I guess once you jump into the volcano you got to do
something, so swimming around in it that sounds like a good one.
but anyway, as a new scout master swimming in the volcano, one of the
things I'm struggling with is youth leadership training.
Our previous two scout masters used a formal Troop leadership training program
with PowerPoint presentations and all that kind of stuff.
I reviewed the presentations and looked at it and I found that it was the same
material that the Air Force taught me in officer leadership training
and, needless to say, is pretty dry, boring material.
From listening to the podcast, I agree with you that lecturing scouts is
really not the best way for them to learn much.
After our last leadership election we did hand out binders to the position
holders with job descriptions when we handed out their patches,
but I think most of the scouts, just kind of doodled in the pages in the binders,
and the binders ended up getting destroyed or lost.
At least my sons did. so I have a few questions for you.
Is formal youth leadership training or Troop leadership training
a requirement, and what do you do in your Troop, Clark?
Do you make a specific day out of training or is it handled within a Troop
meeting? Well, James, those are excellent questions,
and I think training and scouting is. a lot of times we get distracted by the
metrics of training. We want to process as many scouts and
scouts through the training matrix as possible,
stamp them trained and feel as though we've done something.
but I think this misses two important facts.
Now, I'm not saying the training isn't valuable, I really think it's valuable-
but but I think we miss two important facts, especially when we're dealing with
our youth leaders. First, let's dismiss the idea that you
can train leaders in the same way you train people to master physical skills
or processes. Leadership is a complex skill set
and I think that only develops as people actually lead others
in real time, doing real things. Second, let's agree that the most
effective training in anything is experiential
and not theoretical. I'll go so far as to say this,
formal leadership training schemes and classes and things like that
can actually have a lot of unintended effects
that are detrimental. They create an expectation that leadership
is something like mathematics or spelling. You know, if I sit here and I
listen to lectures and I look at PowerPoint slides and if I just
apply myself, I'll become a leader.
Well, that doesn't happen. You have to actually go out and lead and you have
to try and fail and try and fail and learn and develop,
and you need some mentoring and you need some help along the way.
that's how you become a leader. Now, when that doesn't happen instantly, after
they get the patch that says that they're trained, people get discouraged
and they figure that they've failed somewhere along the way or
that somebody's duped them into thinking that they can make this
happen after sitting down and looking at slides or listening to
lectures. So let me take that a little bit further
and say that the way that any of us had learned our work as leaders-
where- whether it's in scouting or out- has been experiential.
Now you can get some key thoughts or concepts in a training course,
but you don't know what's going on until you apply them
in the real world and actually make any kind of progress.
So our big clue on how we train youth leaders
ought to be the broader context of scouting. Scouts don't
volunteer their time to scouting to sit and listen to us explain how to do
things They actually want to do those things.
I don't see it being very useful to put scouts on their behind someplace
looking at PowerPoint presentations or having them do
theoretical exercises in our training courses. I think that the most meaningful
thing they can do is just to do what scouts do.
Let them at it. Trial and error is while all the fun happens
and the actual growth occurs and the actual skill set
of leadership is developed. Neither you or I or anybody drawing breath has
actually walked out of a training course with anything
but something that I would call process knowledge.
The only way that that knowledge becomes useful is when we start
acting on it, and the only way we become skillful
is through continual stages of practice. You refer to being in the Air Force and
sitting through leadership classes, but how did you actually become a leader?
You endured the dry and boring material in the courses.
Did it really help? or were you developing leadership when you were
actually doing stuff? I think if you look back, you agree
with me that any skill any of us have ever developed as leaders
came from doing things. You probably had a couple of times you said to
yourself: you know what they said in that class makes
sense now, but it only happened when you actually did
something in real time, in the real world, that you would have done whether you
sat through the class or not. Now I haven't really answered your questions
specifically at James, so let me get very specific.
First of all, none of BSA youth leadership training
is absolutely required. It's incentivized and suggested and
strongly encouraged in many, many different ways,
but it is not absolutely mandated. Now you asked how we manage this.
Well, we have zero formal leadership training in our troop.
We don't have any meetings or sessions or days or classes of it or anything of
the kind, and the reason that we don't have those
is because I've tried all of these suggested approaches
and they resulted in scouts doing exactly what you described.
when you handed them the binders along with their leadership patches, right,
They kind of doodle in the pages and the binders ended up getting lost or
destroyed and they really didn't make any impact whatsoever.
Instead, what I've learned is we just start doing what scouts do,
and we supply the information or mentoring in the form of training as the
need arises, and we do that on a pretty much on an
individual basis. I do a lot of talking with the patrol leaders council
before and after meetings and during activities,
and so we do something that is not TLT or YLT or NYLT or any of the
initials. I call it OJT. It's on the job training.
What do you need to know right now? Here, it is okay.
How did it go? Well, it didn't go real great. Well, why do you think it didn't
go very great? Well, I don't know. you know, this
kind of happened, that kind of happened. We'll try this
and then we come back. so it's action, reflection,
and then we're going to try again and along with that,
the free sharing of a lot of information and techniques and ideas,
but mostly on an individual basis, because no scout wants to listen to me talk for
20-25 minutes on something. Now, a lot of people
end up doing that on the podcast, but you know that's a little bit different,
right? but no scout volunteered to be a scout
to sit in a chair and listen to me talk to them. They volunteered to be a scout
to do things, and that's the school of leadership. that's where it really
really happens. When we observe and we mentor
and we work along with them, OJT works really really well.
So thanks for that question, James. Hey, if you have a question,
you can get in touch with us and you're going to find out how to do that in
just a moment.
Well, thank you so much for listening to this 250 first
edition of the Scoutmaster podcast. Here's how to keep in touch.
Read the blog at scoutmastercgcom and when you're there, you can subscribe to
receive updates to the blog by email. You can join 4,000 other mobile
scouters who have the Scoutmaster CG app on their mobile devices
and you can get the app on Google Play or at the iTunes app store.
You can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom through the vast
panorama of social media outlets. Join 7,400 other folks
who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook. Tweet along with the
chorus of 1,200 tweeters on Twitter. Pin the poultry tuna's pictures proffered
publicly, with 1,900 other prolific pinners on Pinterest.
Watch us at Scoutmaster CG on YouTube or join the 400 odd folks who form the
exclusive Scoutmaster CG circle on Google Plus.
I can't face Facebook. Twitter makes me better.
I have no interest in Pinterest. I don't put the? U in YouTube. I'm a minus when it
comes to Google Plus. Is that you? Well, that's all right,
Bunky, You can go ahead and zoom into the late 90s and send me an email,
That's right. Get in touch with me, Clark Green, with your comments and
questions and wild ideas at Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom. Did you know that the
Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications of anybody, Not the Boy Scouts of America or any
other scouting organization. They're not endorsed or sponsored by the
Boy Scouts of America or any other scouting organization either. No,
I am sure that all those folks have much better things to do with their
time. Hey, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders and maybe have a little bit of fun along
the way. And speaking of fun, here he is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell. Sir Robert, Good luck to you and good
camping. Why? thank you, sir. Until next time, everyone.